in other world news Burkina faso's
military rulers have given French troops
one month to leave the country
anti-french demonstrations have been
held in the capital wagadugu against the
French military presence many say the
former colonial power has failed to
improve security according to the United
Nations thousands of people have been
killed in Burkina Faso since 2015 and
nearly 3 million displaced in violence
linked to Armed groups let's speak to
ovigue about this he's a policy and
security Analyst at development
reimagined which is an African Affairs
consultancy thank you very much for
joining us on Al Jazeera relations
between France and Burkina Faso have
been going downhill for some time now
what is it that sparked this latest low
and the decision by the military leaders
to suspend the military Accord with
Paris
yeah thanks for having me I would say to
some extent this announcement requesting
that or the money rather that the French
troop move out for Burkina Faso has been
a long time coming because we've seen a
pattern in countries where there's a
military government in place and amateur
government also happens to have a good
relationship with Russia or at least
employing Services of Russian
missionaries on the ground so when you
look at for instance Central African
Republic we saw this the same the same
request the same thing happened where
French troops pulled out in December
last year also also a central Africa
Republic has a very close relationship
with with
um with Russia and with Wagner forces
present there in Mali the same thing the
Malayan government demanded that the the
French troops and even All European
country troops pull out and they did
yeah but it's not just downtown it's not
just down to good relations though with
Russia is it why has anti-french
sentiment spiked and not just in Burkina
faster as you say but in Mali as well
what is France being blamed for
oh there's a whole Litany of crimes of
sins from colonial era and then of
course
the imperialistic campaign that that has
really not been productive on in the
West African region and even central
Africa so it's not just a question of
Cruiser type with Russia but also real
genuine grievances you know against
France because if look at Burkina Faso
for instance by Mali we had a period of
terrorist terrorism in in the mid-2000s
and then early 2000s rather we saw the
French deployed forces and expectation
was that those forces will help with the
security situation but today the
situation of is worse than it was before
you know uh when the friendships came so
there were there's a total disregard for
the support that the French are
providing and not not to mention the
fact that the way they communicate with
the government in in the African
countries does not see many form of
respect effect and that says and respect
for their sovereignty in that regard
yeah
but I mean these these problems cannot
just be solely blamed on France can they
I mean Burkina Faso for example has had
several coups in the last year last year
and a half and that's not down to the
French I would think same thing in Mali
what is the underlying issue here when
it comes to Security in these countries
yeah so the prob the problem the problem
of course cannot be blamed of France in
in in in in any way but what uh what the
governments are saying is they want the
ability to choose their preferred
security partner right and that that and
the problem with that is even if they go
They're going ahead with with choosing
Russia I do not even think the Russians
have the capacity to solve these
problems because the problems that the
countries are facing are
multi-dimensional you're looking at
climate you're looking at on the abject
poverty you're looking you're looking at
countries that economies are not growing
in in any meaningful way uh despite
despite the fact that populations are
actually very younger people are
unemployed and and their populations are
ever going faster than much faster than
the economy so there is a real problem
uh that requires way more than just
military Partnerships and buying more
weapons and troops and all of that and I
think that is the main challenge that
these countries have to say to find a
whole United comprehensive strategy for
National development rather than just
military Partnerships if if Burkina Faso
as Mali did get rid of the French
military presence what replaces it
because military leaders have shown in
the last few years that they can't
really handle the security situation on
their own what replaces it and you
talked about Russia and Wagner would
Paris or even Washington
allow Russian mercenaries to get a
foothold in this region
I I think that is that is the real risk
for for African countries because what
we're seeing developing is not just you
know uh French to being kicked out I I
very well this looks like a
franco-russia proxy war already because
the patterns are really really clear and
that would definitely trigger a response
from United States which is very very
keen to stifle and root out any form of
Russian influence anywhere in the world
particularly in in African countries
where they are seen to be in this field
of Europe of Europe so uh we already
were seeing a U.S passed an act uh that
is called the Malena Russian influence
act and of course that would set a
legislative framework for some form of
sanctions against African countries that
is perceived to have ties with you know
with Russia and then we're seeing
reports that the us is going to you know
Blacklist Wagner's an international
criminal organization so of course that
creates more or in more Avenue to punish
countries that are having ties with you
know with Wagner in particular so I
think African countries will be very
careful in the way they go about you
know trying to
fight one one what they perceive as bad
influence from from France by same time
setting themselves off for punishment or
form of uh the devastating response from
French allies in this case United States
thank you so much for talking to us
about this
joining us there from Ankara